Well, this week, in these troubled and divisive political times, we have this not very typical example of majority rule and what a mess it can make. Our story takes place in a suburban school district an hour north of New York City, East Ramapo, New York. Picture yards, strip-mall sprawl, box stores. Super diverse. You've got big Latino and Haitian and African American populations, some white enclaves, working-class and poor and well-off areas.
在本周，在这个充满困扰和政治分歧的时代，我们看到了一个多数人统治的典型反面教材，以及它可能造成的混乱。我们的故事发生在一个距离纽约市以北一小时车程的郊区学区——纽约州东拉马波。想象一下这里的景象：庭院、带状购物中心、大型零售店。这里非常多元。既有大量的拉丁裔、海地裔和非裔美国人，也有一些白人聚居区，既有工薪阶层和贫困地区，也有富裕地区。
And for a long time now, Hasids have been moving in in large numbers. Hasids are ultra-religious Jews. You've seen the ones in the long black coats and the hats. The men have beards. The women keep their heads covered in public. Like the Amish, they prefer to keep to themselves, so they don't send their kids to public schools. They send them to religious schools called yeshivas, where Yiddish is spoken as the primary language. And in East Ramapo, mostly the Hasids are poor. They're lower middle class.
长期以来，哈西德派犹太人大量迁入。哈西德派是极端宗教化的犹太人。你可能见过那些穿着黑色长外套、戴着帽子的人。男人留着胡须，女人们在公共场合会遮住头发。像阿米什人一样，他们喜欢独处，所以不把孩子送到公立学校，而是送到被称为“叶史瓦”的宗教学校，那里以意第绪语为主要教学语言。在东拉马波，大多数哈西德派教徒比较贫困，属于中下阶层。
And here was their situation. Because they're living in the suburbs, they're paying high property taxes, which, of course, are high because they're paying for local public schools, which their kids don't go to. And then they're also paying for these private schools, these yeshivas. So they're getting squeezed, right?
这就是他们面临的处境。因为他们住在郊区，所以要缴纳高额的房产税。当然，税收很高是因为他们在为当地的公立学校买单，而他们的孩子并不上这些学校。同时，他们还要负担这些私立学校，即“叶史瓦”的费用。所以他们处境艰难，对吧？
And as the Hasidic population got bigger and bigger, that became an issue. Because in New York, these suburban school district budgets go up for a public vote. As the Hasids numbers increase, there were enough of them that they could conceivably go to the polls and vote down the school budget, force cuts. Though, kind of remarkably, that did not happen. And it didn't happen because the public schools and the Hasids worked out a deal, a truce.
随着哈西德派人口越来越多，这成了个问题。因为在纽约，郊区学区的预算需要公众投票表决。随着哈西德派人数增加，他们的人数足以在投票时否决学校预算，迫使学校削减开支。然而，令人惊讶的是，这种情况并没有发生。没发生的原因是公立学校和哈西德派达成了一项协议，一种休战。
Steve White is an activist in school board politics in town.
史蒂夫·怀特是镇上校董会政治活动家。
The original deal that was made many, many years ago was, if we don't investigate whether or not there's education going on in the yeshivas, then the rabbis won't tell their people to vote down our school budget.
多年前达成的最初协议是，如果我们不去调查“叶史瓦”学校是否在进行真正的教育，拉比们就不会告诉信徒去投票否决我们的学校预算。
In other words, the school board won't call in the state to check and see if math and reading and history are being properly taught in the yeshivas, like the state mandates, if the Hasids would just stay away from the polls. Jason Friedman was superintendent for East Ramapo schools for eight years. He says the truce is actually even cruder than that. He says that the yeshivas are entitled to money from public school budgets for certain things like buses and books.
换句话说，如果哈西德派远离投票站，校董会就不会请州政府去核查“叶史瓦”学校是否按州政府要求教授数学、阅读和历史。杰森·弗里德曼曾担任东拉马波学校主管长达八年。他说，这种休战协议实际上比这更粗糙。他说，“叶史瓦”学校有权从公立学校预算中获得资金，用于校车和课本等项目。
And he says the deal was to give the Jewish schools as much money as was legal. Friedman says he would regularly meet with Hasidic rabbis and yeshiva administrators. His pitch was always, we will give you whatever we can. Just don't vote down our budgets.
他说，协议的内容是尽可能合法地为这些犹太学校提供资金。弗里德曼说他经常会见哈西德派拉比和“叶史瓦”的管理人员。他的话术总是：我们会尽力满足你们，只要你们不去投票否决我们的预算。
I think that's what we all worked at. We tried to work out a quid pro quo situation. We could probably never ask a non-public school family to come out and vote yes on a budget. Our hope was that they wouldn't come out, that they would stay away.
我想这就是我们所有人努力的目标。我们试图达成一种“以物易物”的局面。我们可能永远无法要求非公立学校的家庭出来投票支持预算。我们的希望是他们不出来投票，保持远离。
So the Hasidic population grew. And here's a curious demographic fact about East Ramapo. Most of the people in East Ramapo were not Hasids, but most of the children were. Two out of three children in the school district were Hasidic.
哈西德派人口不断增长。关于东拉马波，有一个奇怪的人口统计事实。东拉马波的大多数居民不是哈西德派，但大多数孩子是。学区里三分之二的孩子是哈西德派。
And the Hasids felt cheated because property taxes kept going up to pay for these schools that most of the kids in the district did not attend. And also, the monies and services that the public schools were supposed to be giving the Hasidic schools, they didn't feel like it was enough. So the detente ended.
哈西德派感到受到了欺骗，因为房产税不断上涨，用来资助那些区内大多数孩子并不就读的学校。此外，他们认为公立学校本应提供给哈西德学校的资金和服务也不够。于是，缓和期结束了。
Our story this week is about what happened once it fell apart. And I should say, if you think that you have heard your share of stories about school board fights, what happened next, I totally assure you was like nothing you have probably seen in any school district anywhere. Because it raised such basic questions.
本周我们的故事就是关于这一切破裂后发生的事情。我得说，如果你认为你已经听够了校董会争斗的故事，那我完全向你保证，接下来的事是你可能在任何其他学区都没见过的。因为它提出了如此基本的问题。
It's usually, you know, just a given in our country that people who don't drive still pay taxes for roads, and people who hate the outdoors pay for public parks, and people without kids in the public schools pay for the public schools. Just that's the deal. We all know it. And so what happens when people who do not want to pay for the public schools take over the school board? We're devoting our whole hour to this today.
在我国，人们通常认为，即使不开车的人也要为道路缴税，讨厌户外活动的人也要为公园买单，没有孩子上公立学校的人也要为公立学校出钱。这就是契约，我们都知道。那么，当那些不想为公立学校买单的人掌控了校董会时，会发生什么呢？今天我们整整一小时都在讨论这个问题。
From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. If, by the way, you're listening to this by podcast or internet, there is some cursing in this show, and we have unbeeped the curses in this internet version of the episode. If you prefer a beeped episode, you can get that at our website.
这里是芝加哥WBEZ电台的《这就是美国生活》节目，我是艾拉·格拉斯。顺便提一下，如果你是通过播客或网络收听，本节目中含有一些咒骂内容，我们在这个网络版本中保留了这些词汇。如果你更喜欢有消音的版本，可以在我们的网站上获取。
Ben Calhoun spent months visiting East Ramapo over the course of 2013 and 2014. This is a rerun of our show from a few years ago. He tells the story.
本·卡尔霍恩在2013年和2014年期间多次访问东拉马波。这是几年前我们节目的重播。由他来讲述这个故事。
The dispute that finally shattered the truth in East Ramapo-- there's no way around this-- it's kind of regulate-y and fussy. But this is what ended the peace, what sent the East Ramapo school district into a political brawl that's lasted years. The dispute had to do with special ed students-- Hasidic special ed students.
最终导致东拉马波休战协议破裂的纠纷——对此避无可避——涉及一些行政规范和繁文缛节。但这正是结束和平、使东拉马波学区陷入长达数年政治斗争的原因。这场纠纷与特殊教育学生有关——哈西德派的特教学生。
It was fully in the hands of the district to be a mensch and to do things the right way. They simply refused.
学区完全有能力表现出善意并以正确的方式行事。他们只是拒绝了。
Yossi Gestetner is a political operative, an activist, in the Hasidic communities. He said the problem had to do with the fact that Hasidic special ed students, like other special ed kids, they need expensive therapies and services and education. And the government will pay for those, is required to pay for them. But for that to happen, the district would usually require that the kids go into a public school setting.
约西·格斯特特纳是哈西德社区的一名政治操作员和活动家。他说，问题在于哈西德派的特教学生和其他特教孩子一样，需要昂贵的治疗、服务和教育。政府会为这些买单，也必须买单。但通常情况下，学区要求孩子们进入公立学校环境才能获得这些服务。
The Hasidic and the ultra-Orthodox live in closed communities. And the private yeshivas they send their children to are all Hasidic kids. So just picture-- you're a Hasidic parent with a special needs kid-- maybe with developmental and emotional issues-- and people are telling you, you want to get your kid the help they need, you gotta yank them out of the environment where they're the most comfortable-- the only environment they've ever known-- and send them elsewhere.
哈西德派和极端正统派生活在封闭的社区中。他们送孩子去的私立“叶史瓦”学校全是哈西德派的孩子。所以请想象一下——你是一名哈西德派家长，孩子有特殊需求——也许有发育或情绪方面的问题——而人们告诉你，想让孩子获得所需的帮助，你必须把他们从最舒适、唯一熟悉的环境中拉出来，送到别的地方去。
The parents just want to make sure that the children go to an environment and in a school, an institution, where the language spoken is the language they understand best, the tradition, the religion, and the culture. The way they see it is the state has an obligation to provide the education, and some special needs students get up to $27,000 in funding. Take this $27,000, put it into a different institution, an institution which works for the parent and for the child, a place where it helps the student and the parents best-- especially if it doesn't cost an extra nickel for the taxpayers.
家长们只是想确保孩子们身处一个他们最能理解的语言、传统、宗教和文化的环境中。在他们看来，州政府有义务提供教育，而一些有特殊需求的学生能获得高达27,000美元的资助。拿这27,000美元投入到另一个对家长和孩子都有利的机构中去，这不仅能帮助学生，而且如果这不会让纳税人额外多花一分钱，何乐而不为呢？
In other words, you're going to spend the money anyways. What do you care if it goes to a yeshiva?
换句话说，反正这笔钱是要花的。如果它流向“叶史瓦”学校，你又有什么可在意的呢？
But it's not that simple. You can't do that because of federal education regulations. The government says if it's going to pay for special ed students, then they have to be placed in mainstream environments as much as possible. Congress made that the law because, for years, our country had a real problem-- that special ed kids were being warehoused and isolated. And according to the law, public schools are just considered to be more mainstream than private religious schools.
但事情没那么简单。你不能那样做，因为有联邦教育法规。政府规定，如果要为特教学生支付费用，他们必须尽可能被安置在主流教育环境中。国会之所以立法，是因为多年来，我们的国家确实存在特教孩子被“仓储”和隔离的严重问题。根据法律，公立学校比私立宗教学校更具主流化。
So in East Ramapo, Hasidic parents would often go to the school district and they'd ask for their special ed children to be put in private yeshivas using government money. The school district would say, sorry, we have to follow the law, and the law says no-- which I brought up with Yossi Gestetner.
因此在东拉马波，哈西德派家长经常要求学区用政府资金将他们的特教孩子安置在私立“叶史瓦”学校。学区会说，抱歉，我们必须遵守法律，而法律不允许——这一点我也和约西·格斯特特纳讨论过。
You know, the law just has a very clear--
你知道，法律非常明确地……
Yeah, but I don't--
是的，但我并不……
--and distinct preference for keeping them in a public setting.
……并且明确倾向于将他们留在公共场所。
First of all, if the law tortures the children, the law should be changed. So don't throw around "the law." I mean, law was used to agitate against people all the time. So if the law is broken, don't force the district to spend a million dollars to fight this damn law. Change the law and finish. It's never an argument to me-- like, well, it's against the law. So change the damn law.
首先，如果法律在折磨孩子，法律就应该修改。所以别拿“法律”说事。法律一直被用来煽动对立。如果法律有问题，别强迫学区花一百万美元去和这该死的法律斗争。修改法律就行了。对我来说，这从来都不是理由——比如，“好吧，这违反法律”。那就修改该死的法律。
These complaints and frustrations grew and grew year after year. And so did the Hasidic and ultra-Orthodox population. Eventually, that population was at a point where it wasn't big enough to do what Gestetner is saying-- change the damn law-- but it was big enough to do something else.
这些抱怨和挫折年复一年地增长。哈西德派和极端正统派的人口也在增长。最终，该群体的人数不仅达到了格斯特特纳所说的“修改法律”的要求，而且足以做别的事了。
When it started to matter to the Orthodox, I guess, that they would win-- I want to show you some of these numbers.
我想当他们意识到能赢的时候，这对正统派来说就开始变得重要了——我想给你看看这些数字。
This is Mimi Calhoun. She's a former East Ramapo school parent elected to the school board in 2004. She showed me the school board voting results from the last few decades, how things changed around 2007, 2008, when the Hasidim made a move for control of the school system by taking over the school board.
这是米米·卡尔霍恩。她是一位前东拉马波学校家长，于2004年当选校董。她向我展示了过去几十年的校董会投票结果，显示了2007年、2008年左右局势是如何变化的，当时哈西德派通过控制校董会，试图掌控学校系统。
I want to just say, when you hear these totals, the numbers are going to maybe sound small. Remember, these are suburban school board elections. People winning with a few thousand or even a few hundred votes-- that's the norm in any district around here.
我想说的是，当你听到这些总数时，这些数字听起来可能很小。请记住，这是郊区校董会选举。赢得选举只需几千甚至几百票——这在这一带的任何学区都是常态。
I had about 3,000 votes. My opponent had about 2,000. And those were sort of the numbers that we had. A total of maybe 5,000 people voted. The next year, when Aron Wieder ran--
我当时有大约3000票。我的对手有大约2000票。这就是我们当时的数字。总共可能有5000人投票。第二年，当阿伦·维德参选时……
Aron Wieder was one of the first Hasidic candidates elected to the board.
阿伦·维德是首批当选校董的哈西德派候选人之一。
--he had 6,000 votes, double what I had. That was astonishing. Our numbers stayed about the same, 2,000 or 3,000, and the Orthodox votes tripled. And then their numbers just started increasing.
……他获得了6000票，是我票数的两倍。这太惊人了。我们的票数保持在大约2000或3000，而正统派的票数翻了三倍。然后他们的数字就开始不断增加。
It was almost scary the way they-- it's like, no matter what we did-- like, if we could bring out 5,000 votes, they could bring out 7,000 votes. It was almost as if they could calculate how many people we might be able to get to, and they could bring out that many more people.
这几乎让人害怕……无论我们怎么做——即使我们能动员5000人投票，他们就能动员7000人。仿佛他们能算出我们能争取到多少人，然后他们就能比我们多动员出那么多人。
This is Suzanne Young-Mercer. She's another former school board member. And like she's saying, it's remarkable to look at these elections, to see how the totals start climbing after 2007. It makes me think of that Bugs Bunny cartoon with Elmer Fudd, where they're racing up in the barber chairs. Vote totals go from 5,000 to 8,000, 13,000 16,000 18,000. You can see both sides turn it up, though the Hasidic-backed candidate's always a little bit out front.
这是苏珊·杨-默瑟，另一位前校董会成员。正如她所说，查看这些选举结果非常令人震惊，可以看到2007年之后的总票数是如何攀升的。这让我想起兔八哥和埃尔默·福德那部动画片，他们坐在理发椅上比赛。投票总数从5000涨到8000、13000、16000、18000。你可以看到双方都在发力，尽管哈西德派支持的候选人总是稍稍领先。
Lots of people on the public school side talk about this with bitterness and awe. They tell these stories about Hasidic voters dressed in black filing out of buses.
公立学校阵营的许多人带着痛苦和敬畏谈论这件事。他们讲述着关于哈西德派选民穿着黑色衣服从巴士上走下来的故事。
If my husband was here, he'd say, when he was out in front of the schools handing out stuff, he remembers that someone on the religious side got on a telephone and called to say they needed more people out here to vote. And he said, within minutes, he felt like it was like a sea of people just showed up and were voting. Organized political takeover. Absolutely. Absolutely.
如果我丈夫在这里，他会说，当他在学校门口发传单时，他记得宗教阵营那边有人打电话说需要更多人出来投票。他说，几分钟内，他感觉就像一大群人涌了出来进行投票。绝对是有组织的政治接管。绝对是这样。
The takeover was gradual. The East Ramapo school board has nine members, but only three seats go up for election every year. By 2008, the majority was six Hasidic/ultra-Orthodox, three traditional public school folks.
这次接管是渐进的。东拉马波校董会有九名成员，但每年只有三个席位改选。到2008年，多数席位已由哈西德派/极端正统派占据，仅剩三名传统公立学校成员。
Once the Hasidic majority took control, at first many of the ways it started to remake the district were incremental-- changes to personnel and administration here and there. Kind of quickly, though, restricting the budget and reining in property taxes became a preoccupation. The school board determines the property tax levy when it sets its budget. Controlling taxes meant trimming corners off the budget, dropping extracurriculars, sports teams, cutting music teachers in elementary schools.
哈西德派多数派获得控制权后，起初他们重塑学区的方式是渐进的——比如人事和行政方面的零星变动。然而，很快他们就将削减预算和控制房产税视为重中之重。校董会在制定预算时决定房产税税率。控制税收意味着在预算上精打细算，取消课外活动、体育队、削减小学音乐教师。
They heard that six of their music teachers are going to be cut.
他们听说六名音乐教师将被裁减。
In response, parents and students started to get involved, showing up at board meetings to criticize and question. Grumbling and grousing spiked in this whole new way when the Hasidic-dominated board predicted declining enrollment for the district. And as a result, it planned to close two schools.
作为回应，家长和学生开始参与进来，出现在会议上进行批评和质疑。当哈西德派掌控的校董会预测学区入学率将下降，并因此计划关闭两所学校时，不满和抗议达到了前所未有的程度。
Don't close our schools.
不要关闭我们的学校。
With all the growth in the Hasidic community, people knew there was an intense need for land and buildings for private Jewish schools. So almost immediately, there was speculation the shuttered public buildings would be sold to yeshivas. Gradually, the boardroom took on a new dynamic.
随着哈西德社区的增长，大家都知道他们对私立犹太学校的土地和建筑有强烈需求。所以几乎立即有人猜测，关闭的公立建筑会被卖给“叶史瓦”学校。渐渐地，董事会会议室呈现出一种新的态势。
(SHOUTING) I am a student here! You need to listen to me!
（高喊）我是这里的学生！你们得听我说！
Eventually, on one side of the room, you'd have the public school parents and students. They're mostly black, Latino, some recent immigrants, many poor. More than 70% of students qualify for free and reduced lunch. And then up on the dais, you'd have the Hasidic/Orthodox majority, governing the future of a school system that they'd never send their own kids to.
最终，在会议室的一边，是公立学校的家长和学生。他们大多是黑人、拉丁裔，一些是新移民，许多人很贫困。超过70%的学生符合免费或减价午餐条件。而在主席台上，坐着哈西德派/正统派多数派，主宰着一个他们自己的孩子永远不会就读的学校系统的未来。
Amid the mounting controversy, the Hasidic majority started this regular routine, saying the board needed to go into executive session-- private session in a back room.
在矛盾不断升级的情况下，哈西德派多数派开始了一种固定的程序，称董事会需要进入闭门会议——后室里的私人会议。
No executive!
不要闭门会议！
[INAUDIBLE] --sustained. It's 5 to 1. We're going to go to executive session.
[听不清] ——维持。5比1。我们要进入闭门会议了。
[BOOING AND JEERING]
[嘘声和嘲笑声]
The board would stay locked away for hours on end. Two hours, three hours. And with the board gone, parents and students who had school and work the next day, they'd be left waiting in the boardroom until 11, 12 o'clock at night, waiting for a chance to speak.
董事会可能会在里面锁住几个小时。两个小时，三个小时。董事会离开后，第二天还要上学和工作的家长和学生们只能一直等到晚上11点、12点，等待发言的机会。
Steadily, the wounds and the bruises and the contentious issues multiplied. But if there was a real shot across the bow, one move that transformed a nasty feud into an all-out war, it came down to one particular board meeting, one night, and this dramatic personnel change.
伤口、淤青和争议事项稳步增加。但如果说有一记真正的警钟，将一场恶劣的争吵转化为全面战争，那就是在一次特定的董事会会议上，在那晚，发生了那次戏剧性的人事变动。
[DOOR OPENING]
[开门声]
November 18, 2009. This is the board meeting where all this happened. At the meeting, the board did what had become so usual. It called for an executive session and it started walking out. But as that happened, something unusual took place.
2009年11月18日。这就是发生这一切的董事会会议。在会议上，董事会做了变得习以为常的事。要求进入闭门会议，并开始离开。但就在那时，发生了不寻常的事情。
The remaining, quote unquote, "public school advocates" on the board-- this is the minority-- they stopped on their way out of the room. Generally, they didn't associate with the activists and the parents who'd show up. But tonight, they walked right up to them, and they pleaded. Essentially, what they said was, no matter how long we're behind closed doors, whatever you do tonight, please do not leave.
剩下的所谓的“公立学校倡导者”——这是少数派——在走出房间时停了下来。通常情况下，他们不与那些前来抗议的活动家和家长联络。但今晚，他们直接走向他们并恳求道。他们本质上说的是，无论我们在关起门来讨论多久，无论你们今晚做什么，请千万不要离开。
Executive session. Going back [? for the ?] meeting.
闭门会议。回到会议。
The board didn't come back into the room until nearly a quarter to 1:00 in the morning. And when they get back, what gets put on the table is this kind of puzzling proposal to fire the district's law firm of many years and hire a new guy. And I say puzzling because listen to the specifics.
直到凌晨近1点，董事会才回到房间。当他们回来时，摆上桌子的是一项令人费解的提案：解雇该学区合作多年的律师事务所，聘请一个新人。之所以说令人费解，是因为听听具体细节。
The old lawyer was a local guy, had gone to school in the district, even. He'd done the system's legal work for years and years. And the administration, by every account that I've heard, they really liked him. He charged $120 an hour.
原来的律师是当地人，甚至曾就读于该学区。他多年来一直为系统处理法律事务。据我所知，各方对他的评价都很高。他每小时收费120美元。
The new lawyer was a guy named Al D'Agostino. He was from out on Long Island, more than an hour away. And his contract, it would be for $250 an hour, plus $125 an hour for travel.
新律师名叫阿尔·达戈斯蒂诺。他来自长岛，距离这里一个多小时车程。他的合同是每小时250美元，外加每小时125美元的差旅费。
Add to that this. The new guy had been caught up in a pension investigation by the state of New York. Not exactly desirable. And a confusing move, right? Especially if money is a concern. But people in the room were not confused when this came up. They knew very well who D'Agostino was.
加上这个：这名新人还卷入了纽约州的一项养老金调查中。这可不是什么好名声。这是一个令人困惑的举动，对吧？尤其是当他们声称关心金钱的时候。但房间里的人在提出这个问题时并不困惑。他们很清楚达戈斯蒂诺是谁。
D'Agostino had recently been in the news for representing another school district, one in Lawrence, Long Island. D'Agostino had been involved in a controversial plan that that board was trying to push through-- a plan to close a school.
达戈斯蒂诺最近因代表另一个长岛劳伦斯学区而上过新闻。达戈斯蒂诺参与了该校董会试图推进的一项有争议的计划——关闭一所学校的计划。
The public school board, made up primarily of Orthodox Jewish members who send their kids to private school. A few months ago, the board voted to shut this elementary school.
公立校董会主要由送孩子去私立学校的正统派犹太成员组成。几个月前，董事会投票决定关闭这所小学。
Parents out in Lawrence alleged the plan was to close the school in question and then sell it to a yeshiva. And in fact, it would later be sold to a yeshiva.
劳伦斯的家长们指控，计划是关闭该学校，然后将其卖给一家“叶史瓦”学校。事实上，它后来确实被卖给了一家“叶史瓦”学校。
Attorney Albert D'Agostino says the board has every right to close the school and reassign the kids. And rumors that it will be sold to a Jewish yeshiva are just rumors.
律师阿尔伯特·达戈斯蒂诺表示，董事会有权关闭学校并重新分配学生。关于它将被卖给犹太“叶史瓦”学校的传言只是传言。
Right now, the only decision that's been made is that it will be closed and mothballed.
目前，唯一做出的决定是它将被关闭和封存。
So prior to this meeting, people in Lawrence, Long Island, had been in touch with the public school crowd in East Ramapo. They said, this lawyer is helping our school board do these controversial things. First, they're shutting the school. And also, he's doing this thing where he's helping them put special education students in private yeshivas using public money. Anyway, we've heard your district might hire him. We wanted to warn you.
所以在此次会议之前，长岛劳伦斯的人们就一直与东拉马波的公立学校群体保持联系。他们说，这个律师正在帮助我们的校董会做这些有争议的事情。首先，他们关闭了学校，此外，他还在做一件事，帮助他们用公款将特殊教育学生安置在私立“叶史瓦”学校。总之，我们听说你们学区可能要雇佣他。我们想警告你们。
We didn't know--
我们不知道……
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
[交叉声音]
It wasn't on the agenda and no one--
议程上没有写，也没有人……
In the video of this meeting from this night in East Ramapo, as soon as the majority proposes changing law firms, things unravel super fast. Before you know it, pretty much everyone other than the Hasidic majority is trying to stop the hiring of the new lawyer.
在东拉马波当晚会议的录像中，多数派一旦提议更换律师事务所，事情就迅速失控。不知不觉中，除了哈西德派多数派之外的几乎每个人都在试图阻止聘用新律师。
The superintendent projects that hiring D'Agostino will cost the cash-strapped district as much as $900,000 more per year. Remember, this is already a district that's trimming its budget. The superintendent and the public school advocates on the board, they ask over and over just where is that money going to come from?
学校主管预计，聘请达戈斯蒂诺每年将使现金匮乏的学区多花费90万美元。记住，这是一个已经在削减预算的学区。学校主管和董事会中的公立学校支持者不断询问这笔钱从哪儿来？
While all that's happening, the half dozen public school parents and activists left in the room, they heckle the board.
在这一切发生的同时，留在房间里的那几名公立学校家长和活动家不断地嘲讽董事会。
Crooks!
骗子！
Sometimes they just shout the board down.
有时他们只是大声打断董事会的话。
Shame!
无耻！
And you're trying to save the district money?
你们还想为学区省钱？
Shame!
无耻！
How could you even think of that?
你们怎么想得出来的？
God is watching you.
上帝在看着你们。
That is disgusting!
那太恶心了！
God is watching you.
上帝在看着你们。
That is absolutely disgusting.
那绝对恶心。
And is he going to do the same thing for East Ramapo he's doing for Lawrence, New York?
他会像在纽约劳伦斯做的那样，在东拉马波做同样的事吗？
I can't believe I'm even hearing this.
我简直不敢相信我在听这些。
Perhaps no one tries more desperately to put the brakes on this whole thing than the superintendent at the time. He argues and he pleads and he says, we don't have the money. He also says this whole plan is half-baked and sloppy. He points out that there's no strategy to hand off the district's current cases from the old lawyers to the new one.
当时的主管可能在竭力阻止这一切。他辩论、恳求，说我们没有这笔钱。他还说整个计划是不成熟且草率的。他指出，根本没有策略将学区现有的案件从旧律师移交给新律师。
I've heard nothing about a transition plan.
我没听说有任何过渡计划。
He says, in disbelief, the district has cases in court tomorrow. There's no reason to do this so hastily.
他难以置信地表示，学区明天就有案件要上法庭。没有理由如此草率地行事。
You should table this now. You're talking millions of dollars. You can't, as a board, change attorneys overnight. I take that back. You can.
你们现在应该搁置这个议题。你们谈论的是数百万美元。作为董事会，不能一夜之间更换律师。我收回这句话。你们可以。
Mr. [? Wieder, I'm ?] [? sorry-- ?]
维德先生，对不起……
You have the right to do that. It would be insane to do it. You're putting this district in major jeopardy, major jeopardy.
你们有权这样做。但这样做简直是疯了。你们正在让这个学区陷入重大危险，重大危险。
The superintendent is still asking where all the money will come from when Aron Wieder, the leader of the Hasidic majority, cuts him off, calls for a vote.
当哈西德派多数派的领袖阿伦·维德打断他并要求投票时，主管仍在询问这笔钱从哪里来。
Are you going to answer the question of where the money is?
你们打算回答这笔钱从哪里来的问题吗？
No, he's not.
不，他不打算回答。
All those in favor, say aye.
赞成的人请说“赞成”。
Five members in the Hasidic majority vote yes. The three other board members present vote no. The motion passes, and Al D'Agostino becomes the board's new lawyer.
五名哈西德派多数成员投了赞成票。在场的另外三名董事会成员投了反对票。动议通过，阿尔·达戈斯蒂诺成为董事会的新律师。
With the new lawyer, Al D'Agostino, at the legal rudder, the board forged ahead with the two school closures. Remember, the reasoning had been that the board was predicting a significant decrease in public school enrollment. Enrollment never actually did decline. But the two schools were shuttered and put on the market, and the board eventually sold both to yeshivas.
在新律师阿尔·达戈斯蒂诺的法律掌舵下，董事会强行推进了学校关闭计划。记住，他们的理由是预测公立学校入学人数将大幅下降。入学人数实际上从未下降。但两所学校被封存并投放市场，董事会最终将它们都卖给了“叶史瓦”学校。
It also changed its approach to special ed placements. It replaced the district's head of special education, who Hasidic parents had had a ton of beef with, and then the district started placing special ed students in private Jewish schools in very large numbers.
它还改变了特殊教育安置的方式。它撤换了学区的特教主管——该主管与哈西德派家长的关系非常紧张——随后学区开始大规模地将特教学生安置在私立犹太学校。
You might wonder, how would they do that if it's against the law? The answer is Al D'Agostino, who imported a strategy he'd used in the other school district.
你可能会想，如果这违反法律，他们怎么能这样做？答案是阿尔·达戈斯蒂诺，他从另一个学区引入了这一策略。
Now, I won't get into all the gritty details here, but the short of it is that D'Agostino kind of cut a messy loophole into the regulations, one that allowed the board to put special education students into yeshivas using public money. These questionable placements were soon piling up in East Ramapo. And state officials were desperately trying to intervene, warning the district that the practice was against the law.
现在，我不会在这里讨论所有棘手的细节，简而言之，达戈斯蒂诺在法规中切开了一个混乱的漏洞，允许董事会用公款将特教学生送入“叶史瓦”学校。这些存在疑问的安置案例很快在东拉马波堆积如山。州政府官员极力试图干预，警告学区这种做法违反法律。
Also high on the priorities list for the new Hasidic majority was reining in property taxes. And with the levers of power now in its possession, it launched what's pretty much been a systematic defunding of the East Ramapo public schools. Just to get a picture of how this played out inside the schools, I went to a high school principal named Jean Fields. She'd just retired from one of the district's two high schools, Ramapo High School.
新的哈西德派多数派名单上的另一项首要任务是控制房产税。随着权力的在手，他们发动了基本等同于系统性削减东拉马波公立学校经费的行动。为了了解这种情况在学校内部的体现，我去找了一位名叫简·菲尔兹的高中校长。她刚从该学区的两所高中之一——拉马波高中退休。
The yearbooks-- this is 2007, '08, '09, '10.
这是2007、08、09、10年的年鉴。
Fields showed me four yearbooks from when the school board really started cutting. You can actually see the yearbooks get thinner and thinner and thinner.
菲尔兹向我展示了校董会开始大幅削减开支时期的四本年鉴。你实际上可以看到年鉴变得越来越薄。
It's like half the size by the time you get to 2010.
到2010年，它几乎只有原来的一半大。
And that's not declining enrollment. That's things disappearing from the school.
那不是因为入学人数下降，而是因为学校里的东西在消失。
Right. That's things disappearing.
对，东西在消失。
Fields went page by page, showing me what was cut. The business department-- that was several pages-- all eliminated.
菲尔兹一页一页地展示被削减的内容。商业系——那是好几页的内容——全部被取消。
All of these courses are gone.
这些课程全部没了。
There were other departments cut by 80%. Full pages of honor societies, sports, JROTC, AP classes, clubs, dance, home ec, administrative staff. District-wide, the cuts have been sweeping.
其他部门被削减了80%。整页的荣誉社团、体育、初级预备役军官训练营（JROTC）、AP课程、俱乐部、舞蹈、家政、行政人员。在全学区范围内，削减是全面的。
Here's a partial list from the last five years. All deans, all social workers eliminated. All assistant principals at the elementary school level, music instruction for elementary school kids, funding for field trip buses-- all eliminated. That came with cuts to administration, guidance counselors, teaching assistants, maintenance, assistant principals, among lots of others. Kindergarten was reduced from full-day to half-day. System-wide over the last six years, the district's laid off 22% of all its teachers. At one point, Jean Fields says, there got to be so few teachers in her building, there was a conversation about whether the school should just let seniors go halfway through the day.
这是一份过去五年的部分名单。所有的院长、所有的社会工作者都被解雇了。小学部的所有助理校长、小学儿童的音乐指导、实地考察巴士的资金——全部被削减。同时削减的还有行政、指导咨询师、助教、维护人员、助理校长等等。幼儿园从全日制缩减为半日制。在过去六年中，全学区裁掉了22%的教师。简·菲尔兹说，有一次她所在学校的教师人数少得可怜，甚至有人讨论学校是否应该让高年级学生中午就提前放学。
[DRUM LINE PLAYING]
[鼓乐演奏]
From what I can tell, nothing and no one was sacred. Most high schools have things that are sources of pride. It might be a sports team or a theatre program, a debate team. For Fields' school, it was their marching band. It won big awards. It was featured in the Denzel Washington remake of The Manchurian Candidate. In 2012, the board laid off the band's director.
据我所知，没有什么人或事是神圣的。大多数高中都有值得自豪的东西。可能是运动队、戏剧节目或辩论队。对于菲尔兹的学校来说，那是他们的行进乐队。它赢得了大奖，还被丹泽尔·华盛顿翻拍的《满洲候选人》引用。2012年，董事会裁掉了乐队指挥。
We would always complain to the school board about scheduling. And what would happen is the school board would always respond and say, well, that's not true. You guys are making it up.
我们总是向校董会抱怨排课问题。而校董会总是回应说，那不是真的。你们在编造。
Olivia Castor went to Spring Valley, the other of the district's two high schools. She was there during the biggest cutbacks. And while she was there, so many teachers were laid off, students started having a hard time filling their schedules with actual classes, a complaint that Castor took to the board, where she was told the problem wasn't real.
奥利维亚·卡斯托就读于该学区另一所高中——斯普林瓦利高中。她在削减最严重的时期在那里就读。当时太多的老师被裁，学生们开始难以排满正式课程。卡斯托向校董会提出了投诉，但被告知问题不是真实的。
So I was tired of them saying that's not true, so this is a document that we put together about--
所以我厌倦了他们说那不是真的，所以这是我们整理的一份文件，关于……
Castor set out to prove the problem was real. She gathered evidence into this eight-page packet that she showed to me. It includes real student schedules from her high school. These are from 2012, so this is a snapshot from later in the cutbacks.
卡斯托决心证明问题的真实性。她收集证据整理成了这份八页的文件，并展示给我看。其中包括她高中时期的学生课表。这是2012年的，是削减后期的一个快照。
And if you look at the schedules, you'll see three things. You'll see study halls, lunches, and community service-- filler periods. Normally, during those periods, you'd have electives or classes or APs that you're taking. For this student, they have like four lunches and two study halls in one day, and you have eight periods in a day.
如果你看课表，你会看到三件事：自习课、午餐和社区服务——充数时期。通常在这些时段，你应该有选修课或课程，或参加AP课程。对于这个学生来说，他们一天中有四顿午餐和两节自习，而一天总共只有八节课。
And this is grade 12? So this is a senior.
这是12年级？所以这是高三学生。
Yeah, that's a senior. You have three lunches back to back and a study hall.
是的，这是高三。你有三节连着的午餐和一节自习。
Like the student would have period one, environmental science. Then they would have a study hall. Then they would have lunch. Then they would have lunch. Then they would have lunch. Then they would have public affairs. Then they would have lunch again. And then they would have algebra and trigonometry.
就像这名学生第一节是环境科学。然后是自习课。然后是午餐。然后还是午餐。然后还是午餐。然后是公共事务课。然后又是午餐。然后是代数和三角学。
Yeah. So basically, three periods out of the eight are learning, and then five out of the eight-- more than half-- is not learning.
是的。所以基本上八节课中有三节在学习，而五节——超过一半——没有学习。
The former principal, Jean Fields, she confirmed this was a problem in her school, too. At one point, she told the administration the problem was so bad some kids might take five years to graduate because they just couldn't take enough required classes. Just to say, the reason this situation could exist-- New York State education law has no regulations about how many hours of instruction a student actually has to get throughout the school day.
前校长简·菲尔兹证实她学校里也存在这个问题。有一次，她告诉行政部门问题太严重了，一些孩子可能需要五年才能毕业，因为他们根本无法修够足够的必修课。需要说明的是，这种情况之所以存在，是因为纽约州教育法对学生全天必须接受多少小时的教学没有任何规定。
Olivia Castor eventually took the schedules she'd collected and showed them to the school board. I asked her how they responded. She said, they told me those must be fake.
奥利维亚·卡斯托最终带着她收集的课表展示给校董会看。我问她校董会是如何回应的。她说，他们告诉她，那些肯定是假的。
As you can imagine, this course of events, this kind of breakdown, this kind of environment, it's produced a sprawling epic of public confrontation. Year after year filled with all the usual kinds of events-- rallies outside Central Office, press conferences, handmade signs, student walkouts, sit-ins. Though even the predictable events often have these details that seem to speak to the peculiarity of this specific war. Like, say, protests where hundreds of students fill a gymnasium and chant things like, "Cut the lawyer."
如你所料，这一连串的事件、这种崩溃、这种环境产生了一部宏大的公开对抗史诗。年复一年，充满了各种司空见惯的事件——中央办公室外的集会、新闻发布会、手写标语、学生罢课、静坐示威。甚至那些可预测的事件往往也包含着一些细节，似乎道出了这场特殊战争的特殊性。比如，成百上千名学生挤满体育馆，高呼“裁掉那个律师”之类的口号。
Cut the lawyer! Cut the lawyer! Cut the lawyer! Cut the lawyer!
裁掉律师！裁掉律师！裁掉律师！裁掉律师！
Another unique part of this big, sprawling fight is that, with the board regularly shutting itself behind closed doors in executive session, in their absence, parents and students would end up holding these strange, impromptu, non-meeting meetings, where they only had each other to talk to. There's a video that I can't quite shake of a meeting like this. It's from December 2012, a meeting about possible budget cuts. Among the parents, there's a mother. Her name is Cassandra Edwards.
这场宏大斗争的另一个独特之处在于，董事会经常将自己锁在闭门会议中，在他们不在的时候，家长和学生最终会举行一些奇怪的、临时性的非会议，在那里他们只能彼此交谈。有一个我挥之不去的视频片段，那是2012年12月的一次关于预算削减的会议。在家长中有一位母亲，名叫卡桑德拉·爱德华兹。
Good evening. I think I come from a different perspective. I come from the perspective of being angry at this point.
大家晚上好。我想我来自不同的视角。我来自此刻感到愤怒的视角。
As Edwards takes the mic, she stands in front of this auditorium. She's still in her winter coat, facing the crowd. And as she starts to talk, you can see that the board has left the room. They've gone into executive session. All their empty chairs are on the auditorium stage behind her, one for each public official who won't hear anything she's about to say.
当爱德华兹拿起麦克风时，她站在礼堂前。她还穿着冬大衣，面对着人群。随着她开始说话，你可以看到董事会已经离开了房间。他们进入了闭门会议。他们所有空荡荡的椅子都在她身后的礼堂舞台上，每一个空座都属于一个即将对她所说的话充耳不闻的公职人员。
They're not shooting our kids with guns. They are stealing their education. And we are acting as if it is normal. We are acting as if it's OK. We are allowing them to sit in another room and not demand them to come out and speak. Who is the problem? We are the problem! We need to get angry about what's happening with our kids!
他们没有用枪射杀我们的孩子，他们在窃取他们的教育。而我们表现得好像这是正常的。我们表现得好像这没关系。我们允许他们坐在另一个房间里，而不要求他们出来说话。谁才是问题所在？我们就是问题所在！我们需要对孩子们身上发生的事情感到愤怒！
[CHEERING]
[欢呼声]
And we're not angry!
而我们并不愤怒！
I just want to pause here because you'll notice the crowd, they're totally with her. But as she keeps talking, she gets more and more upset, and it turns into this kind of upset that it's hard to cheer for.
我想在这里暂停一下，因为你会注意到人群完全支持她。但随着她继续说下去，她变得越来越不安，那种不安让人难以再欢呼。
We're losing our kids! And nobody's angry! Nobody's mad! There's not options for our kids. No options. They're setting up prisons for our kids.
我们要失去我们的孩子了！没有人愤怒！没有人疯狂！我们的孩子没有选择。没有选择。他们在为我们的孩子建立监狱。
I'm wondering, is there nothing good about this district and its work? Wouldn't it be nice and productive if you would compliment the board once in a while?
我在想，这个学区及其工作就没有一点好的地方吗？如果你偶尔能称赞一下董事会，难道不是既美好又有建设性的吗？
No. No.
不。不。
Is it really against your nature?
这真的违背了你们的本性吗？
Less often, but occasionally, folks from the Hasidic and ultra-Orthodox communities would show up at board meetings, and they'd return fire. In this video, a man named Jay Grossman lays into the public school parents and students.
虽然少见，但偶尔会有来自哈西德派和极端正统派社区的人出现在董事会会议上进行还击。在这段视频中，一个名叫杰伊·格罗斯曼的人严厉抨击了公立学校的家长和学生。
When you utilize this microphone to spew hatred and negativity constantly, you have accomplished one thing. You have accomplished that I, my friends, family, and acquaintances became more involved in what's going on here. And trust me, our presence here in this room is growing and will grow from week to week. When you constantly attack one of ours, we will be here to defend. We will be here to counterattack if needed. Rest assured--
当你利用这个麦克风不断散布仇恨和消极情绪时，你只达成了一件事。你让我的朋友、家人和熟人更多地参与到这里发生的事情中。相信我，我们在房间里的存在感正在增长，并且会每周都在增长。当你不断攻击我们中的一个人时，我们会在这里进行防卫。如果需要的话，我们会在这里反击。请放心……
He's threatening us.
他在威胁我们。
--Mr. Wieder is going nowhere, and we're going nowhere.
……维德先生哪儿也不会去，我们也哪儿也不会去。
Gradually, shouting, open hostility, profanity, that became the norm on the school board. And in terms of how deep the political chasm got, there's a couple artifacts I'll include for you. The first is just an anecdote.
渐渐地，大喊大叫、公开敌意和粗言秽语成为了校董会的常态。关于政治鸿沟的深度，我有几个样本可以提供给你。第一个仅仅是一个轶事。
At one point, people close to this situation who thought this breach could be repaired, they tried to broker peace talks, a sort of diplomacy summit. A lawyer that specializes in negotiations was brought in. He was a former sergeant in the Israeli military, and folks thought he could make inroads with both sides. Someone close to the negotiation says everybody sat down and the Hasidic leadership was blunt. In about these words, a Hasidic board member said, we have all the power. Why would we negotiate? If we do, we only have things to lose.
曾经一度，那些认为这种裂痕可以修复的人试图促成和平谈判，一种类似于外交峰会的活动。有人请来了一位专门从事谈判的律师。他曾是以色列军队的中士，人们以为他能在这双方之间取得进展。一位接近谈判的人说大家都坐了下来，但哈西德派领导层直言不讳。大意是，一位哈西德派董事会成员说，我们拥有所有的权力。为什么要谈判？如果我们这样做，我们只有失去的东西。
There's also a candid document, one that points to the political will behind the board and what it was doing. It's this letter written around the time when all this was beginning. A prominent real estate developer in the Hasidic community, a man named Yehuda Weissmandl, wrote a letter to the local newspaper.
还有一份坦率的文件，指向了董事会背后的政治意志及其所作所为。这是在这一切开始时写的一封信。哈西德社区的一位著名房地产开发商，名叫耶胡达·魏斯曼德尔，给当地报纸写了一封信。
"Dear fellow taxpayer in the East Ramapo school district, again and again, I read about how upset you are about the members of the school board, how we bloc-voted them in, how we don't have the interests of the schoolchildren at heart. Well, let's take a closer look at that.
“致东拉马波学区的同胞纳税人，我一次又一次地读到你们对校董会成员有多么不满，我们是如何以集团投票方式让他们当选的，我们是如何不把在校学生的利益放在心上的。好吧，让我们仔细看看。”
For many years, you took our tax money-- year after year, increase after increase-- and you never had any problem with that. But when we finally get together and say that's enough, that is a problem.
“多年来，你们拿走了我们的税款——年复一年，增长后再增长——你们对此从未有过任何问题。但当我们终于团结起来说受够了的时候，这就成了问题。”
I have a solution. How about giving all of us the option to bow out of the public school system and keep our money in our pockets? You want our money and our silence. Sorry, you cannot have it all your way."
“我有一个解决方案。让我们所有人都拥有退出公立学校系统的选择权，并把我们的钱留在自己的口袋里，怎么样？你们想要我们的钱和我们的沉默。抱歉，你们不能事事都如愿以偿。”
The author of that letter, Yehuda Weissmandl, is now the president of the East Ramapo school board.
那封信的作者耶胡达·魏斯曼德尔，现在是东拉马波校董会的主席。
Ben Calhoun. Coming up, ugliness gets uglier. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio when our program continues.
本·卡尔霍恩。接下来，丑陋变得更加丑陋。芝加哥公共广播电台节目继续。
This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. We're hearing today about a strange case of what democracy and what majority rule can look like. It's the story of the East Ramapo, New York, school district, where a group of parents whose kids did not attend public schools took over the public school board for years. In East Ramapo, the non-Hasidic families continued in each election cycle to try to win additional seats on the school board, turn back the Hasidic majority. They never were able to. Ben Calhoun's story from 2014 continues.
这里是《这就是美国生活》，我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天我们听到了一个关于民主和多数统治看起来会是什么样子的奇怪案例。这是纽约东拉马波学区的故事，一群孩子不上公立学校的家长接管了公立校董会多年。在东拉马波，非哈西德派家庭在每个选举周期继续尝试赢得校董会的额外席位，扭转哈西德派多数派，但他们从未成功。本·卡尔霍恩2014年的故事继续。
I've tried to talk to Hasidic members of the board, current and former. I've made multiple requests in person and on the phone to talk to Aron Wieder, the first leader of the majority. I've also reached out multiple times to the current board president. Neither will return my calls. I've issued a blanket invitation to the whole school board, which is now made up entirely of Hasidic-backed members. I've done that twice via the district clerk with no takers.
我尝试与董事会的哈西德派成员交谈，包括现任和前任。我曾多次当面或通过电话要求与第一位多数派领袖阿伦·维德对话。我也曾多次联系现任董事会主席。两人都不回我的电话。我曾两次通过地区职员向整个校董会发出过公开邀请，如今校董会完全由哈西德派支持的成员组成，但无人应答。
The one Hasidic board member who would talk to me is a former board president named Morris Kohn. He sat on the school board from 2009 to 2011, so he was there for some of the most severe cuts. Kohn told me he'd talk to me because he didn't want people to think he'd been, quote, "a madman." This is how Kohn says the story went from the Hasidic and ultra-Orthodox side. He says, flat out, the community wanted control of the board to do all the things we've outlined-- rein in property taxes, change special ed, and to make sure private yeshiva students got all the government money they could for things like busing and books.
唯一愿意与我交谈的哈西德派董事会成员是曾任董事会主席的莫里斯·科恩。他在2009年至2011年期间担任董事会成员，所以他在最严重的几次削减期间都在场。科恩告诉我他愿意与我交谈，因为他不希望人们认为他是一个所谓的“疯子”。这就是科恩从哈西德派和极端正统派角度讲述的故事。他说，非常直白地说，社区想要控制董事会以完成我们概述的所有事情——控制房产税、改变特教政策，并确保私立“叶史瓦”学校的学生能获得尽可能多的政府资金，用于校车和课本等项目。
They were there for that one main purpose, is to make sure the services private students are supposed to get are given, and that the public school was functioning properly.
他们的目的只有一个，就是确保私立学生应得的服务得到落实，并确保公立学校正常运作。
Is there something inherently uncomfortable about a system being governed by folks who don't use that system or wouldn't want to use that system? Is there something that's uncomfortable just about that?
被那些不使用该系统或不愿意使用该系统的人所治理，这在本质上是否让人感到不安？仅仅是这一点，就让人感到不安或不公平吗？
Well, it's very understandable people would see it that way. It's uncomfortable or unfair. Having said that, every person living in a district, if they're investing money in a business and they feel, OK, the business is not being run properly, then I would get myself in there and try to get those improvements done.
嗯，人们会这样看是可以理解的。它令人不安或不公平。话虽如此，区内的每个人，如果他们对某项业务进行投资，如果他们觉得这项业务经营不当，那么我也会进去并尝试让那些改进得到落实。
Let me explain the second part of what Kohn had to say because this is less obvious. Kohn says going into all this, the Hasidic community saw the public schools as a system in trouble, bloated with unions and inefficiency, and a good slap of fiscal conservatism would go a long way.
让我解释科恩所说的第二部分，因为这不太明显。科恩说，在进入这一切时，哈西德社区认为公立学校是一个陷入困境的系统，充满了工会和低效，而如果进行财政保守主义的冲击，将会有很大的作用。
But then, once the Hasidim had control, there were all kinds of external financial factors that came crashing down-- the recession, the state property tax cap. And like school districts all across the state, he says, East Ramapo was suddenly super hard-up.
但后来，一旦哈西德派掌握了控制权，各种外部财务因素随之崩溃——经济衰退、州房产税上限。他说，和州内各地的学区一样，东拉马波突然变得非常艰难。
State cuts, government funding-- things were getting increasingly difficult to provide even the most simple services. And the board needed to do sometimes draconian cuts, which obviously, parents and students alike did not like that, which is very understandable. And people were feeling, I don't want the school board to do this. I don't want the school board to cut that. Our hands were tied. Like it or not, this is what we need to do.
州政府削减开支，政府拨款——即使提供最简单的服务也变得越来越困难。董事会不得不进行有时甚至残酷的削减，这显然家长和学生都不喜欢，这是可以理解的。人们感觉，我不希望校董会这样做，我不希望校董会削减那个。我们的手被束缚了。无论喜欢与否，这就是我们需要做的。
Kohn says it wouldn't have mattered who was on the board. Cuts were inevitable. But he says there was so much mistrust, nobody could see this.
科恩说无论谁在董事会上都一样。削减是不可避免的。但他表示，因为互不信任，没有人能看清这一点。
It would always be the private school parents against the public school parents, and I felt in such an environment, no matter what you will do, in one way or another, eventually you will be blamed for it.
这总是私立学校家长对抗公立学校家长，我觉得在这样的环境中，无论你做什么，最终你都会被责怪。
This argument-- that cuts were inevitable in East Ramapo, that they were making the same tough choices as other districts-- it's not supported by the facts.
这种论点——即东拉马波的削减是不可避免的，他们正在做出与其他学区相同的艰难选择——并不被事实支持。
I've analyzed the budgets of all the school districts in the county for the last 10 years. All the other regular school districts in the area, districts that faced the same economy and made it through without the same kinds of massive cuts, the main thing they were doing was raising property taxes. During the five years that East Ramapo was making its biggest cuts, all of the normal neighboring school districts raised their property taxes by an average of more than 25% just to get by. During the same five years in East Ramapo, the Hasidic-controlled board raised taxes by just 9%.
我分析了过去10年县里所有学区的预算。该地区所有其他普通学区，面对同样的经济情况并熬过去而没有进行同样大规模削减的学区，他们所做的主要事情是提高房产税。在东拉马波进行最大削减的那五年里，所有邻近的普通学区为了维持生计，平均将房产税提高了25%以上。而在东拉马波的这五年里，由哈西德派控制的董事会仅将税收提高了9%。
Some more numbers. During the last 10 years, every comparable school district in the county grew its budget by an average of 50%. East Ramapo's budget grew by 33%. Which, to a layperson, you might say, well, oh, the budget grew. How bad could that be? I actually kind of thought that at first.
再看看其他数字。在过去10年里，县里每个相当规模的学区预算平均增长了50%。东拉马波的预算增长了33%。作为一个外行，你可能会说，嗯，预算增长了。那能有多糟？我最初确实也这样想。
But I talked to school administrators and experts who said that the costs the Hasidim and other conservatives say are out of control actually are rising alarmingly fast-- pensions, health care, union contracts, cost of living. Those things grow by so much that a 30% budget increase, that isn't growth. That's devastation.
但我与学区管理人员和专家交谈，他们表示哈西德派和其他保守派声称失控的那些成本，实际上正以惊人的速度增长——养老金、医疗保险、工会合同、生活成本。这些东西的增长幅度如此之大，以至于30%的预算增长根本不是增长。那是灾难。
One uniquely volatile element in this chemical reaction, something unexpected that's become a chapter unto itself, is the outsized role of the board's controversial lawyer, Albert D'Agostino. In some ways, it seems like he was just symbolic because of how he was hired. In that way, he became a sort of hood ornament for the Hasidic majority.
在这个化学反应中一个极其不稳定的因素，一件意想不到的事情，已经成为一个独立章节的，是董事会有争议的律师阿尔伯特·达戈斯蒂诺的作用。从某些方面来看，他似乎仅仅是象征性的，因为他的聘用方式。就这样，他成为了哈西德派多数派的一种“车头装饰”。
But in other ways, he became an actual central player. He's functioned as an overt advocate for the Hasidic majority in board meetings. He's become a fixture at the end of the board table, right up on the dais. After months of going to meetings, I found he acts like an unusual combination of attorney, legal architect, consigliere, and bully. A lot of the time, if board members shy away from conflict, D'Agostino steps in as a combatant.
但在其他方面，他成为了一个实际的核心参与者。他在董事会会议上发挥了哈西德派多数派公开代言人的作用。他成为了董事会桌尽头、主席台上的一名固定成员。在参加了几个月的会议后，我发现他表现得像是一名律师、法律架构师、咨询师和恶霸的奇怪组合。很多时候，如果董事会成员回避冲突，达戈斯蒂诺会以战斗者的身份介入。
A video of one board meeting that gives you a sense of this-- a few months after D'Agostino arrived, a former student came to a meeting.
董事会会议的一段视频让你对此有所了解——达戈斯蒂诺到来几个月后，一名前学生来到会议上。
My name is Lorenzo Labitigan.
我叫洛伦佐·拉比蒂根。
Lorenzo Labitigan was a district graduate in his first year at Yale, and he'd come back because he'd heard there were possible cuts to advanced placement classes. He wanted to plead to keep those. At some point, he makes a comment about D'Agostino, about how the board's paying all this added money for a lawyer.
洛伦佐·拉比蒂根是学区毕业生，当时在耶鲁大学读大一，他回来是因为听说AP课程可能面临削减。他想请求保留这些课程。在某个时候，他评论了达戈斯蒂诺，说董事会支付了所有这些额外费用来雇佣一个律师。
Then he says something about D'Agostino having stained credentials. He's referring to the fact that the state of New York accused D'Agostino of illegitimately taking a state pension. Anyway, the kid says "stained credentials."
然后他说了些关于达戈斯蒂诺资历有污点的话。他指的是纽约州指控达戈斯蒂诺非法领取州养老金的事实。总之，这孩子说了“资历有污点”。
--with stained credentials.
……资历有污点。
[CLAPPING]
[掌声]
D'Agostino jumps in and the crowd erupts.
达戈斯蒂诺插话，人群爆发了。
Mr. Chairman, if I might-- if I might--
主席先生，如果我能……如果我能……
[CROWD SHOUTING]
[人群叫喊]
It's hard to hear him in there. D'Agostino's cutting off the student's comment, saying, "Mr. Chairman, if I might-- if I might--"
很难听到他在说什么。达戈斯蒂诺打断了学生的评论，说道：“主席先生，如果我能……如果我能……”
I take great exception to your term "stained credential." I graduated from an Ivy League college myself, sir, and I don't remember anybody coming up with as ignorant a statement as you just made. You know nothing about me.
我对你说的“资历有污点”一词提出强烈反对。我自己也是从常青藤联盟学院毕业的，先生，我不记得任何人能说出像你刚才那样无知的话。你对我一无所知。
[CROWD SHOUTING]
[人群叫喊]
If you want to challenge my reputation, do it to me personally.
如果你想挑战我的声誉，那就亲自来找我。
Are you threatening me?
你在威胁我吗？
Right there, the student's asking quizzically, are you threatening me?
就在那一刻，学生困惑地问，你在威胁我吗？
No, I'm telling you. I am not a stained lawyer, and I won't take it from anybody, including a freshman Yalie. You're showing your ignorance.
不，我在告诉你。我不是一个有污点的律师，我不会从任何人那里接受这种评价，包括一个耶鲁大一新生。你在展示你的无知。
Excuse me, sir. You need to have respect for these children who are graduates--
抱歉，先生。你需要尊重这些毕业生孩子……
He's not a child. He's an adult. If you make outrageous, defamatory statements, you're going to have to take the response.
他不是孩子。他是成年人。如果你发表离谱的诽谤言论，你必须承担后果。
OK, for the record, as far as these pension allegations go, the New York Comptroller's Office accused D'Agostino of taking a $106,000-per-year New York State pension, one the state says he wasn't eligible for because he wasn't a government employee.
好的，记录在案，关于这些养老金指控，纽约州审计长办公室指控达戈斯蒂诺领取每年106,000美元的纽约州养老金，州政府称他不具备领取资格，因为他不是政府雇员。
There's lots of videos of D'Agostino blowing up, yelling at parents, school administrators, pointing fingers in people's faces. There's a well-known incident when D'Agostino verbally abused one of the public school parents. According to a newspaper reporter who saw this, an Honor Roll student came to the parent's defense, and D'Agostino called the kid a piece of shit, asking the child, "Do you want a piece of me?"
有很多视频显示达戈斯蒂诺暴跳如雷，对家长、学校行政人员大吼大叫，指着人们的脸。有一个著名的事件是达戈斯蒂诺在言语上虐待了一名公立学校的家长。据目击此事的报纸记者说，一名优等生站出来为那名家长辩护，达戈斯蒂诺称这孩子是“狗屎”，并问那孩子：“你想尝尝我的厉害吗？”
Still, though, the most remarkable example of the bizarro role the school board's law firm has taken on in this conflict, it doesn't actually involve D'Agostino but another attorney from his firm, a lawyer named Chris Kirby. The set-up here is in a board meeting. The lawyer, Kirby, he smirked at a public school parent while she was talking about her special needs kid. When the lawyer, Kirby, eventually left that meeting, an activist named Tony Luciano, he called Kirby an asshole.
尽管如此，校董会律师事务所在这场冲突中扮演的角色最令人瞩目的例子，实际上并不涉及达戈斯蒂诺，而是他事务所的另一名律师，名叫克里斯·柯比。背景是一次董事会会议。律师柯比在一名公立学校家长谈论她有特殊需求的孩子时冷笑。当律师柯比最终离开那次会议时，一位名叫托尼·卢西亚诺的活动家称柯比是“混蛋”。
But so Kirby leaves. He's gone. The meeting ends. This group of parents and activists walk out. Luciano, who videotapes every board meeting, is still rolling as they leave. In this video, you see the sidewalk as the parents head to the parking lot. And then a car drives up. I had Luciano, the activist, walk me through what happened.
柯比离开了。他走了。会议结束了。那群家长和活动家走了出来。卢西亚诺，那个录下每一次董事会会议的人，在他们离开时还在录像。在这段视频中，你可以看到家长走向停车场的人行道。然后一辆车开了过来。我让活动家卢西亚诺带我重温了发生的事情。
A car's just pulling up.
一辆车正开过来。
Uh-oh. Uh-oh.
糟了。糟了。
I didn't know whose car was pulling up. And he gets out.
我不知道是谁的车开了过来。他下车了。
Call the police. Call the police!
报警。报警！
Obviously, he laid in wait for us.
显然他埋伏在那等我们。
The lawyer, Kirby, walks right up to the parents. He's the first one you hear in this next clip.
律师柯比径直走向家长们。他是你在下一段剪辑中听到的第一个人。
You wanna call me an asshole now? Huh?
你现在想叫我混蛋吗？啊？
I already did.
我已经叫过了。
Oh, did you, you fucking cocksucker? Huh? Huh? What? You got a problem?
哦，你叫了吗，你他妈的混蛋？啊？啊？什么？你有意见？
Wait. So can we just pause it right here? Because all you can see is the front of his shirt. What's going on right now?
等等。所以我们能在这里停一下吗？因为你只能看到他的衬衫正面。现在发生了什么？
He's standing directly in front of me.
他正站在我面前。
And in terms of just how far away from you he is, how much space is between your chest and his chest?
至于他离你多远，你的胸部和他的胸部之间有多少空间？
None.
没有。
Oh, he's actually up against you?
哦，他实际上贴着你？
Chest to chest, yeah. Yeah. We're touching. And I noticed that his hands are in a clenched fist, so he's ready to strike me.
胸贴胸，是的。是的。我们碰在一起了。我注意到他的手紧握成拳，所以他准备打我。
I don't got a problem.
我没意见。
Yeah, you do. I'm standing in your way. You gonna do something about it? Yeah, I didn't think so.
是的，你有。我挡着你的路了。你要对此做点什么吗？是的，我料想你不会。
No.
不。
Take a picture of his license plate.
拍下他的车牌。
At this point, the lawyer, Kirby, he walks back to his car. Parents are saying, take a picture of his license plate. And Kirby stands next to his car, giving the parents the middle finger. And he keeps saying--
此时，律师柯比走回了他的车。家长们说，拍下他的车牌。柯比站在车旁，对着家长们竖中指。他不停地说……
Take a picture.
拍张照。
Here you go.
给你。
Here you go. Take a picture.
给你。拍张照。
Take a picture. Take a picture.
拍张照。拍张照。
Take a picture.
拍张照。
The women get on their phones and they call the cops. And then-- I don't even know. Things just go bananas.
女人们拿出手机报警。然后……我甚至不知道。事情变得一团糟。
We're calling the police right now.
我们现在就报警。
You gonna hide behind a bunch of women?
你想躲在一群女人后面吗？
Ramapo Police are on their way.
拉马波警察正在赶来的路上。
Go hide behind your women.
去躲在你的女人们后面吧。
There is a lawyer who's threatening parents.
有一个律师在威胁家长。
Look at him hiding behind all the women.
看他躲在所有女人后面。
We need someone here right away.
我们需要有人马上过来。
What a man. What a tough guy.
真是个男人。真是个硬汉。
He's not hiding behind anybody.
他没躲在任何人后面。
Please hurry up--
请快点……
Who are you hiding behind, your paycheck?
你躲在谁后面，你的工资单后面吗？
Shut up, you fat cunt.
闭嘴，你这肥婆。
Don't tell-- you just-- OK. That-- that did it.
别告诉……你刚才……好吧。那……那太过了。
Don't let him leave. Don't let him leave!
别让他走。别让他走！
That did it.
那太过了。
That did what?
什么太过了？
That did it.
那太过了。
Come on. That's it. That's it. Fuck you, you fucking bitch.
来吧。就是这样。就是这样。去你妈的，你这他妈的贱人。
Is that how you talk to your wife? You're either drunk or high.
你就是这样跟你妻子说话的吗？你不是喝醉了就是嗑药了。
If I were married to you, I'd blow my fucking brains out.
如果我娶了你，我他妈的就自杀了。
Honey, you wouldn't be married to me. You're not man enough. Trust me. You are not man enough.
亲爱的，你不会娶我的。你还不够男人。相信我。你还不够男人。
I'm sitting there with a smirk. Fuck you! I can sit there. They're paying me to sit there. I work for the board, not for you.
我正坐在那里冷笑。去你妈的！我可以坐在那里。他们付钱让我坐在那里。我为董事会工作，不是为你。
Chris, whoa, why are you--
克里斯，哇，你为什么……
This shows you that the board, they feel like they're immune. And it's a culture that the--
这表明董事会觉得他们是不可触碰的。这是一种……
You trying to intimidate me? Is that what you're doing?
你想恐吓我吗？你是在这样做吗？
--school board members have fostered among the attorneys because their disdain for the community has trickled onto the attorneys. They can do anything and get away with it.
……校董会成员在律师中培养出来的文化，因为他们对社区的蔑视已经渗透到了律师身上。他们可以做任何事而逃脱惩罚。
After this happened, there was a lot of outcry-- embarrassing coverage, newspaper editorials. The board did say this was too much. It announced publicly it would get rid of D'Agostino's firm. But it would actually take them two years before they'd cut ties with him and the law firm.
这件事发生后，引发了巨大的哗然——尴尬的报道、报纸社论。董事会确实表示这太过分了。它公开宣布将解雇达戈斯蒂诺的事务所。但他们实际上花了两年时间才切断与他和他的律师事务所的联系。
If I can, I need to change gears here and talk about part of this story that you may have noticed-- that this whole story treads near some of the most destructive anti-Semitic stereotypes in existence. In the last several years, as East Ramapo has divided into us versus them, questions of anti-Semitism have cut a wide path.
如果可以的话，我需要改变一下角度，谈谈这个故事中你可能已经注意到的部分——整个故事触及了现存最具破坏性的反犹太刻板印象。在过去的几年里，当东拉马波分裂为“我们”和“他们”时，关于反犹太主义的问题划出了一条宽阔的界限。
There have been troubling incidents, cases of kids throwing rocks at school buses full of Hasidic yeshiva students. In one case, a rock hit a young boy and fractured his skull. Last summer, three teenagers drove into Hasidic neighborhoods, shooting at people on the street with a paintball gun. They later told police they'd gone out that night to, quote, "shoot Jews."
发生了令人不安的事件，比如孩子们向装满哈西德派“叶史瓦”学生的校车扔石头。在一次事件中，一块石头击中了一个小男孩并导致其颅骨骨折。去年夏天，三名青少年开车进入哈西德派社区，用彩弹枪射击街上的人。他们后来告诉警察，那天晚上他们出来，引述，“射击犹太人”。
While a lot of activists, parents, and students have tried to keep anyone associated with them from venturing into anti-Semitism, most people have seen glimpses of it. Olivia Castor, the student with the schedules, she told me about organizing rallies to protest the board.
虽然许多活动家、家长和学生试图阻止任何与他们有关的人陷入反犹太主义，但大多数人还是看到了它的踪迹。奥利维亚·卡斯托，那个有课表的学生，告诉我关于组织集会抗议董事会的事情。
So when we were doing the rally, people would be like, "F Jews," or something like that. And we were just like, you need to get out.
所以当我们举行集会时，人们会说“F犹太人”之类的。我们当时就说，你们得离开。
Oh, so people would actually just try and make that a chant.
哦，所以人们实际上只是试图把它变成一句口号。
Yeah. You know, they'd say it one time and I'm just like, no. No. I will shut that down right away.
是的。你知道，他们说了一次，我就说，不。不。我会立即阻止它。
I heard more than one story about students, some very young, going up to teachers and asking, why are the Jews doing this to us? And this dynamic takes a simple political turf war-- a school board fight-- and it turns it into something uglier on all sides.
我听到不止一个关于学生的故事，有些非常年轻，走到老师面前问，为什么犹太人要对我们做这种事？这种动态将一场简单的政治地盘争夺战——一场校董会斗争——变成了各方都更加丑陋的事情。
They put up their own propaganda videos.
他们发布了自己的宣传视频。
This is Tony Luciano again, the guy who tapes all the meetings, the guy who gets confronted in the parking lot. A few years ago, Luciano ran for school board and someone put up a video against him. I had him show it to me.
这是托尼·卢西亚诺，那个录下所有会议的人，那个在停车场被对质的人。几年前，卢西亚诺竞选校董，有人发布了一段针对他的视频。我让他展示给我看。
Let's see. This one.
来看看。这一段。
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[音乐播放]
It says, "East Ramapo News, Luciano Running for School Board." I didn't put this up.
上面写着，“东拉马波新闻，卢西亚诺竞选校董”。这不是我发布的。
The video is essentially an attack ad. A school board election attack ad. In it, there's a clip of Luciano making a comment about Hasidic board members washing their hands of the consequences of their actions, which, for complicated reasons having to do with Pontius Pilate and 2,000 years of Jewish history, this ad says is code for anti-Semitism. And then violin music kicks in.
视频本质上是一个攻击性广告。一个校董会选举攻击广告。里面有卢西亚诺的一段评论，说哈西德派董事会成员对自己行为的后果“洗手不管”，由于涉及彼拉多和2000年犹太历史的复杂原因，该广告称这是反犹太主义的暗号。然后小提琴音乐响起。
But to try to absolve--
但是为了试图免除……
So now they're showing a picture of Nazi soldiers high-stepping. "Vote no to bigotry and hatred." And again, they show the Germans, Nazi soldiers, high-stepping.
所以现在他们展示了一张纳粹士兵高抬腿行进的照片。“对偏见和仇恨投反对票”。而且他们再次展示了德国纳粹士兵高抬腿的照片。
Did you say that there was one that was harsher and more offensive than this one?
你说过有一个比这个更严厉、更具冒犯性的视频？
Oh, yeah. Oh, yeah.
哦，是的，哦，是的。
How did the other one go?
另一个是怎么样的？
It showed Adolph Hitler talking. It showed people in the concentration camps, in Auschwitz. It showed--
它展示了阿道夫·希特勒在说话。它展示了奥斯威辛集中营里的人们。它展示了……
One of the other public school activists, Peggy Hatton, the mom who gets cursed out in the parking lot, a while ago someone took a picture of her, put a mustache on it, split-screened it with a picture of Hitler, and that got tweeted through the Hasidic and Orthodox community.
另一位公立学校活动家，佩吉·哈顿，那个在停车场被咒骂的母亲，不久前有人拍了她的照片，贴上一撇小胡子，与希特勒的照片做成对比图，并在哈西德派和正统派社区中推特传播。
The tension of all of this-- real anti-Semitism, accusations of anti-Semitism, the fear of anti-Semitism, and the fear of being accused of anti-Semitism-- it casts a fog over this whole situation. There's an incident from a school board meeting. It's kind of well-known by people here.
这一切的紧张关系——真正的反犹太主义、对反犹太主义的指控、对反犹太主义的恐惧，以及因被指控反犹太主义而产生的恐惧——给整个局面笼罩上了一层迷雾。有一个来自董事会会议的事件。当地人对此非常熟悉。
It was the board president at the time, Daniel Schwartz, who was leading the Hasidic majority in 2012. And he gave this eight-minute speech at a board meeting. Public school activists have nicknamed it Schwartz's Rant. He starts out by bringing up a few different troubling incidents.
那是当时的董事会主席丹尼尔·施瓦茨，他在2012年领导哈西德派多数派。他在一次董事会会议上发表了八分钟的演讲。公立学校活动家将其昵称为“施瓦茨的咆哮”。他首先提到了一些令人不安的事件。
The children in our schools are walking up to their teachers and, apparently in response to the demographic makeup of this board, have been telling their teachers, many of whom are of the Jewish faith, that they hate Jews.
我们学校的孩子们走到老师面前，显然是对董事会人口结构的回应，告诉他们的老师（其中许多是犹太信仰的人）他们恨犹太人。
The thing that Schwartz does after this, where things get super complicated, he starts to cast a blanket accusation of anti-Semitism over all the people who had been opposing the school board's decisions. He starts by bringing up a student who'd come to a meeting to challenge the board.
施瓦茨在此之后所做的事情让情况变得极其复杂，他开始将反犹太主义的笼统指控抛向所有反对董事会决定的人。他首先提到了一个前来会议挑战董事会的学生。
During another controversial period this past year, a young student stood up at that rostrum there and stated that, as far as she is concerned, this board cares more about money and taxes than it does about people. That too raises an age-old anti-Semitic trope of Jewish obsession with money.
在去年另一个争议时期，一名年轻学生站在讲台上说，就她而言，这个董事会关心金钱和税收胜过关心人。这也引发了犹太人对金钱痴迷的古老反犹太主义寓意。
I simply won't have it. I will not tolerate-- I will not have any such statements ever being made in this district. Suggesting that Orthodox Jews who do not send their children to the public school lack the moral authority to hold this office hearkens back to the admonishments of Saint Augustine, who famously stated that the Jews should be allowed to live but never be allowed to prosper. And that paved the road to Auschwitz and the crematory of Treblinka.
我简直无法接受。我绝不会容忍——我绝不会允许本学区再出现任何此类陈述。暗示那些不把孩子送到公立学校的正统派犹太人缺乏担任此职的道德权威，这让人想起圣奥古斯丁的告诫，他曾著名地声称应该允许犹太人活着，但绝不能允许他们繁荣。而这为通向奥斯威辛和特雷布林卡火葬场铺平了道路。
To suggest that we lack the moral authority to sit in these seats, let me tell you right now-- you don't like it, find yourself another place to live because this is the United States of America.
要说我们缺乏担任这些席位的道德权威，让我现在就告诉你们——你们不喜欢它，就找个别的地方住吧，因为这是美利坚合众国。
Yes, it is.
是的，它是。
Not only that--
不仅如此……
[ONE PERSON APPLAUDING]
[一个人鼓掌]
To complicate all this even more, consider the racial dynamics of this situation. On one side, the Hasidim, all white. On the other side, the public school families, almost entirely black and Latino. But in school board meetings, in rallies, campaign literature, interestingly, racism doesn't come up the way anti-Semitism does. The activists told me they try to leave it off the table because they know how explosive it is. But in private conversations, it comes up.
为了让这一切更加复杂，考虑一下这种情况下的种族动态。一方面是哈西德派，全白人。另一方面是公立学校家庭，几乎全是黑人和拉丁裔。但在校董会会议、集会、竞选宣传品中，有趣的是，种族主义并没有像反犹太主义那样被提及。活动家告诉我，他们尽量避而不谈，因为他们知道这有多么爆炸性。但在私下交谈中，它还是会被提及。
I spent months talking to people on both sides of this situation, and I think whatever role anti-Semitism has in all of this, the bigger split is the chasm between an isolationist religious community and everyone else. I think secular people sense from these religious groups an implied disdain and disapproval for their way of life. And in return, secular people feel a disdain and disapproval back towards the religious community over lots of issues, including things like how these groups often treat women. This animosity, it's ambient, and it's hard to pin down. But it's corrosive.
我花了几个月时间与双方的人交谈，我认为无论反犹太主义在其中扮演了什么角色，更大的鸿沟是孤立主义宗教社区与其他人之间的鸿沟。我认为世俗的人从这些宗教团体中感知到一种对他们的生活方式隐含的蔑视和不赞同。作为回报，世俗的人感到一种反向的蔑视和不赞同，涉及许多问题，包括这些群体通常如何对待女性。这种敌意是氛围性的，很难确定，但它具有腐蚀性。
I personally don't see a whole lot of anti-Semitism.
我个人并没有看到太多的反犹太主义。
Suzanne Young-Mercer deals with all kinds of people in her job running the emergency room at Mount Sinai, one of New York's largest hospitals. Again, she served on the school board. And she told me this anecdote that encapsulates a lot of what I saw in Ramapo.
苏珊·杨-默瑟在运营纽约最大的医院之一——西奈山医院的急诊室时，与各种各样的人打交道。同样，她曾在校董会任职。她告诉我这段轶事，概括了我在拉马波所看到的很多东西。
One day, I was walking down the street. And there was a Hasidic woman who called me. She said, miss? Miss? And I looked at her. And she said, I wonder if you could help me. She's in her home. So I walk over and I say, what do you need me to do?
有一天，我走在街上。有一位哈西德派女士叫我。她说，小姐？小姐？我看着她。她说，我想请你帮个忙。她在家里。所以我走过去说，你需要我做什么？
Turned out, it was Friday-- Sabbath-- and the woman had a switch that she wasn't allowed to flip on her fridge. Young-Mercer went in and flipped it for her.
结果那天是周五——安息日——那位女士冰箱上有一个开关，她不能动。杨-默瑟进去帮她关上了。
And she took out these little fruits or something. And she said, oh, thank you so much. Here, take this. They're really very good. You can take these. And so I took them. She said, thank you so much. And I left the house.
她拿出这些小水果之类的东西。她说，哦，太感谢你了。拿着这个。它们非常好吃。你可以拿着。所以我拿着了。她说，太感谢你了。我就离开了那个房子。
I don't understand why a little tiny switch on her refrigerator couldn't be pushed down by them without God sending his wrath down. I don't understand that whole part of it. But I was willing to help them because why not? You're my neighbor. You asked me for some help. As little as that was to do, certainly it's something I could do. I know truly in my heart that if I needed help, if I was standing on a street corner and I needed help from one of them, they would walk over me before they'd help me. And that's the difference between them and us.
我不明白为什么冰箱上一个小小的开关，在上帝不降下愤怒之前，他们就不能自己按下。我不明白这整件事。但我愿意帮助他们，因为为什么不呢？你是我的邻居。你请求我帮忙。尽管这件事微不足道，但这当然是我能做到的。我心中确实知道，如果我需要帮助，如果我站在街角需要他们其中一个人的帮助，他们会在帮我之前就从我身上跨过去。这就是他们和我们之间的区别。
I don't think Suzanne Young-Mercer is anti-Semitic. But I do think anytime you say, I know in my heart what everyone from this one particular group thinks and feels, that's trouble. And in East Ramapo, that trouble is all around you.
我不认为苏珊·杨-默瑟是反犹太主义者。但我确实认为，每当你断言“我知道这个特定群体中的每个人是怎么想和感受的”时，那就是麻烦。而在东拉马波，这种麻烦无处不在。
There are enough Hasidim to control the local school board in East Ramapo, but there aren't enough to control New York State. And increasingly, the board is not just at war with the parents and their district, but with state government.
哈西德派的人数足以控制东拉马波的当地校董会，但不足以控制纽约州。董事会不仅在与家长和他们的学区交战，而且越来越多地与州政府交战。
In 2010 and again in 2012, the New York State Education Department reviewed what the district was doing-- placing Hasidic special ed students in private schools using public money. Both times, the state said, stop what you're doing. It's against both federal and state law. We'll cut your funding. This changed nothing. The district did not comply. What it did was sue the state. The court said the state was right, but the board is appealing.
2010年和2012年，纽约州教育局审查了学区的行为——用公款将哈西德派特教学生安置在私立学校。两次，州政府都说，停止你们的行为。这违反了联邦法和州法。我们会削减你们的经费。这没有改变任何事。学区没有遵守。它所做的是起诉州政府。法院判决州政府正确，但董事会上诉了。
In 2011, the New York State Comptroller conducted an audit of the district's finances. The audit determined that the board has engaged in inaccurate record-keeping with discrepancies in the millions of dollars, loose monitoring of money going to private schools, sloppy bill payment, and just all kinds of bad management.
2011年，纽约州审计长对学区的财务进行了审计。审计认定，董事会从事了不准确的记录保存，存在数百万美元的差异、对流向私立学校的资金监控松散、账单支付草率，以及各种糟糕的管理。
The other big category here is the district's real estate deals. The board did close two schools and sold them to yeshivas. One of those deals, in particular, it's been a complete mess. In short, the district got a bid from a yeshiva for the building. The bid was for $3 million. The school building was appraised at $6 million. So that's a hard deal to justify-- until the board rushed out and got the school reappraised for $3 million and sold it to the yeshiva at that price. Activists challenged the new appraisal, and the state took their side and nixed the deal. The appraiser recently pleaded guilty to fraud charges.
另一个大类别是学区的房地产交易。董事会确实关闭了两所学校并将它们卖给了“叶史瓦”学校。其中一项交易特别乱。简而言之，学区收到了“叶史瓦”学校对该建筑的报价。报价是300万美元。该校舍估价为600万美元。所以这是一项难以辩护的交易——直到董事会急忙找人将该学校重新估价为300万美元，并以该价格卖给了“叶史瓦”学校。活动家对新的评估提出了质疑，州政府站在他们一边并取消了交易。评估师最近承认了欺诈指控。
Just this summer, New York Governor Andrew Cuomo appointed a monitor to watch the district. The district's response? The current board president wrote a letter saying the state was, quote, "acceding to the demands of bigots and lending officials sanction to their prejudice," end quote.
就在今年夏天，纽约州长科莫任命了一名监督员来监视该学区。学区的回应呢？现任董事会主席写了一封信，称州政府是“屈从于偏执狂的要求，并给予官员对其偏见的制裁”。
I've never had to write anybody in before. So I'm voting for Governor Cuomo, OK?
我以前从没不得不写谁的名字。所以我投了科莫州长的票，好吗？
This past May, I met up with public school activist Steve White. This was school board election day. I stood in the booth with him as he wrote in Governor Cuomo three times for the East Ramapo school board. He had to do that because, for the first time since all this started, there were no public school candidates running. After years of not winning a single race, the public school crowd failed to recruit anybody to run.
去年五月，我见到了公立学校活动家史蒂夫·怀特。那是校董会选举日。我站在投票箱前，看他三次写下科莫州长的名字参加东拉马波校董会竞选。他不得不这样做，因为自这一切开始以来第一次，没有公立学校候选人参选。在多年没有赢得一场竞选后，公立学校阵营没能招募到任何人参加竞选。
During much of this fight, Steve was kind of the field general for the public school side. We stood outside his polling place, where, in recent years, he says there were huge lines. But today, there was no one. We were the only two people on the sidewalk.
在这场斗争的大部分时间里，史蒂夫算是公立学校阵营的前线指挥官。我们站在他的投票站外，他说近年来那里有排长队的情况。但今天，一个人都没有。我们是人行道上唯一的两个人。
If someone wanted to organize this year, they could very well have gotten their candidates together, gotten their signatures signed, handed them in, shown up here today to do battle with your cards in hand and as people arrive to vote. It's just that no one did.
如果有人想在今年组织起来，他们完全可以召集候选人、签好名字、递交上去，今天出现在这里，带着他们的卡片，在人们到达投票时进行战斗。只是没人这样做。
Does that feel like giving up at all?
这感觉像是放弃了吗？
I guess it does. Yeah, I guess it does.
我想是的。是的，我想是的。
White says, these days, even if his fellow public school activists organize better than ever, he doesn't think they could win a seat. The Hasidic community is now just too big. He estimates they're half of registered voters now. That door is closed, he told me.
怀特说，如今，即使他的公立学校活动家同伴比以往任何时候都组织得更好，他也不认为他们能赢得席位。哈西德社区现在太大了。他估计他们现在占注册选民的一半。那扇门关上了，他告诉我。
Eventually, he stopped the car at Hillcrest Elementary School. This is the school that was appraised for $6 million and sold for $3 million to a yeshiva. The state stepped in and voided the sale, but it eventually went through this summer for $4.9 million.
最后，他把车停在希尔克雷斯特小学。这就是那所被估价600万美元并以300万美元卖给“叶史瓦”学校的学校。州政府介入并作废了交易，但在今年夏天，它最终以490万美元的价格成交。
We walked around the back of the building, and you could see why the school was so sought after. Directly behind it sits one of the largest Hasidic communities in the area. The only thing separating the two was a field and a small chain-link fence.
我们在建筑后面走了一圈，你就能明白为什么学校如此抢手了。在它后面直接就是该地区最大的哈西德社区之一。分隔两者的只有一片田地和一个小铁丝网围栏。
Yeah, so there's the way you can walk through. We don't have to go any further. You see those buildings there through the fence? Yeah. And see where people are walking through? That's where they broke a hole in the fence.
是的，所以你可以从这里走过去。我们不用再往后走了。你看到围栏那边的那些建筑了吗？是的。看到人们走过的地方了吗？那就是他们把围栏弄破的地方。
As we stood there, a steady stream of Hasidic families made their way through a hole in the fence and towards the school building. Though, today, they weren't there for school, for the yeshiva. This was election day, and this yeshiva, it doubles as a polling place. The Hasidic families walking towards the building, they were all on their way to cast their votes.
当我们站在那里时，源源不断的哈西德派家庭通过围栏上的洞向学校建筑走去。虽然今天他们不是为了上学，为了“叶史瓦”学校而来。这是选举日，而这个“叶史瓦”学校，同时也是投票站。哈西德派家庭向建筑走去，他们都在去投票的路上。
Ben Calhoun is one of the producers of our show. So right after this program first aired back in 2014, the fiscal monitor from the state wrote up a report about East Ramapo, calling it, quote, "a school district in crisis." Since then, the state legislator has continued keeping an eye on the district, appointing new monitors, and passing a bill that requires the state education commissioner to approve the local East Ramapo school board budget.
本·卡尔霍恩是我们节目的制片人之一。所以就在这个节目于2014年首次播出后，来自州政府的财政监督员写了一份关于东拉马波的报告，称其为“陷入危机的学区”。从那时起，州议员继续密切关注该学区，任命了新的监督员，并投票通过了一项要求州教育专员必须批准东拉马波当地校董会预算的法案。
In the pension case against Al D'Agostino-- thats the one that accused him of getting a state pension while not a state employee, the case that led the student to say that he had stained credentials-- the state ended up ruling in favor of D'Agostino.
在针对阿尔·达戈斯蒂诺的养老金案件中——就是那个指控他在不是州雇员的情况下领取州养老金的案件，那个导致学生说他资历有污点的案件——州政府最终裁定达戈斯蒂诺胜诉。
In the 2015 school board elections, there were pro-public school candidates on the ballot again. Today, one of them is on the board. This past school year, the school board accepted funds from the state to restore some of the things that have been cut. All-day kindergarten was brought back, along with some music and art classes. Public school advocates say that things are slowly getting better. Just this week, the community voted on and passed a budget that increases summer programs, arts, bilingual classes, and special education.
在2015年的校董会选举中，支持公立学校的候选人再次出现在选票上。今天，其中一人就在董事会中。过去一个学年，校董会接受了来自州政府的资金，以恢复一些被削减的项目。全日制幼儿园恢复了，音乐和艺术课程也恢复了一些。公立学校倡导者说情况正在慢慢变好。就在本周，社区投票通过了一项增加暑期项目、艺术、双语课程和特殊教育的预算。
[MUSIC - "DON'T THROW MY VOTE AWAY" BY DAVE STEIN]
[音乐 - "DON'T THROW MY VOTE AWAY" BY DAVE STEIN]
I can't believe I'm even hearing this! That is disgusting!
我简直不敢相信我在听这些！那太恶心了！
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带回更多《这就是美国生活》的故事。